foreign
it has survived the test of time a bond
forged by common democratic ideals and
values so says the U.S state Department
that has withstood challenges embraced
changes
no matter the difference between its
leaders
it was Winston Churchill himself half
American by way of his mother who coined
the phrase the special relationship and
a sentiment echoed by the current prime
minister Rishi sunak who continued to
hold a U.S green Card while he was the
chancellor of the exchequer
he's a Stanford man
but it is not without its tests not
least for the UK still adapting to life
outside the European Union
the UK is no longer part of one of the
largest markets in the world it is on
its own it is it hasn't you know sorted
out its relationship with Europe that's
improving that helps but America can no
longer look to the UK as the country
that it feels most comfortable with
that's part of one of the biggest
markets in the world but it's not just a
question of Economics defense forms a
major part of the ties between London
and Washington such as orcas a recently
formed strategic trilateral alliance
between Australia the UK and the US in
the indo-pacific region
Britain beat off competition from France
to build nuclear-propelled submarines
France called it a stab in the back
yet the UK's decision to lead support
for Ukraine after the 2022 Russian
invasion as part of a transatlantic
response left the U.S in no doubt of the
country's continuing military goals and
objectives
there will be much to discuss during Mr
sunak's trip to Washington and not least
of all the ongoing war in Ukraine which
has strengthened ties between the U.S
and the UK and while the relationship
between the former prime minister Boris
Johnson and President Biden perhaps fell
a little short of special there is a
renewed interest on both sides to repair
that
part of that involves stemming the rapid
advances in artificial intelligence
which experts warn could cause human
extinction the US and the EU are already
collaborating on the issue while the UK
is pitching itself as an international
hub for AI regulation less severe than
the EU but tougher than the US and
opening up a new technological Frontier
in this historical partnership Sony
Gallego Al Jazeera London